let me give a compliment to gerard
everest
we are live if we had to take a picture
of gerard from the day he came here
versus today
night and day i know we're alive i just
want to say that's a compliment well he
got a great
you got a great haircut thank you well
now he's uh he's uh he looks better he's
got the new haircut i don't know whether
you call that a vanilla ice haircut or a
hollywood aircraft he's got a good
haircut
okay by the way what you guys hear about
is simone biles oh yeah she got taken
off the olympics yeah just now like uh
30 minutes or an hour ago what's going
on injury no no no anxiety
mental mental pressure mental anxieties
it's real out there
was this common 10 years ago 12 years
ago in the olympics
anxiety depression i had anxiety and
depression when i played but we just
drank it away
like that was you know i'm actually
being serious i'm i am being serious
yeah
i am an alcoholic literally
self-medicated that's why there's so
many
uh i i don't know i i think that uh look
media scrutiny is is
different it's just different i've never
had media scrutiny at this level
well more than media scrutiny it's all
the commentary that comes with the media
scrutiny yeah
if you read in the comments it's i could
get ugly i've learned the hard way do
not
read the comments i will tell them good
or the valuetainer
the valuetainers i will say are very
interesting at least in the comments
they're very
funny i do whether they whether they
like me or they don't they're very funny
the commentary actually is like there's
some actually legit stand up can you
actually read the comments or no not
really not really no
okay on valuetainment economics i do i
think a lot of like
did you see his post yesterday so he
posts a job opportunity right and we we
talked about it last week why didn't i
say that the guy is notorious for taking
care of his employees
right but he puts out something he's
like i need immediate hire
all right i'm gonna i'm gonna give
somebody a job and the first thing is
like you're not paying enough screw you
this and that and
this woman comes in and was like i would
never work for you and
he's like he's in the comments yes you
should see it yeah it was unbelievable
he's like i don't think he really fit
the culture and you're looking
you you look at her profile and it was
perfect it was perfect it was like uh
she was basically like antifa jane man
like it was like i could just imagine
her in this office place today so it was
two job postings for bookers sixty
thousand dollars oh i heard a
plus bonus plus four one k plus benefits
right can i apply
we're willing to pay relocation feeder
here this guy from dubai
says yeah it's pathetic why are you
paying them this much so what i do is i
go to
salary.com ziprecruiter and different
website that tell you what
what a talent booker's salary is
in south florida it's 42 000 or 58 000.
i put 60 thousand problems bonus so
i comment back i said you haven't been a
booker before do you know what a booker
gets paid and these guys go back and
forth anyways the point is
you know one i enjoy trolls i have fun
with them
to me it doesn't bother me what bothers
me is the fact that
you know you're seeing today with
olympics
the amount of pressure that you know i'm
trying to see if this is real pressure
that athletes have
on anxiety how to deal with it is it
hey if you're doing that as well i'm
also going to do it since you can also
step out and not want to compete then
i'm going to do it because even the girl
from japan the tennis player lost
yesterday i don't know if you're going
to say
is this is this a is this something
where sports has to take seriously to
give
because she proposed giving days off
like here's the amount of days i could
have for media
is that something sports should consider
hey i got five days off today i don't
want to talk to the media about it okay
so i have two feelings on this two
feelings that that i feel pretty strong
do they both involve alcohol
no but wow okay yeah uh the first one is
man
that whenever you're doing any sort of
athletics right
and i can only imagine the in the
olympics specifically where you're where
it's
four years of training for this one
moment it's it's all this pent up
aggression
most of sports and this is when when i
was playing this is what people don't
understand
like most of it sucks most of it's not
fun they see you out there and you're
hitting the ball and you're running
you're having fun and you're pimping
home runs and they're like this is fun
man
those three hours are the most fun hours
that you can have those hours under the
lights are amazing
but everything leading up to that sucks
it really does man the practice
the the the protocols depending on like
how strict the team in the organization
is
like you feel like you have no personal
autonomy at all and you're you've given
so much of your life to this dream
you've missed
birthdays you've missed weddings you've
been away from your family you go across
the world like you
literally give everything up give up
relationships you give everything up for
this
it's it's all there but you got to kind
of find your why
so for a lot of us it's like i love my
family the chance for generational
wealth like i'm i'm gonna
i'm gonna do something for my family now
with the olympics like
like it was it was the love of country
it was i'm gonna represent my people
back home i'm gonna represent i'm
standing up for something
i don't know if that love of country is
still there yeah i did i don't even
think that's a major factor
in this moment i think it's just the you
want to achieve great can you pull up
the twitter
twitter what i'm saying is that when you
when
when you're on an individual level i can
tell you the biggest difference between
college baseball for me and minor league
baseball was i
gave a [ __ ] whether my team won in
college i loved my teammates and i cared
if we won
and in my leagues i didn't matter of
fact all i wanted to do was go to a
different team i just wanted to move up
i wanted to do well enough that i could
leave these guys behind you know what
i'm saying so i think when you
individualize your sport so much
you you end up taking all of the the
the negative too much on you because
you're not able to
you you're not able to to relish in the
team victory you're not able to relish
in
in what we're doing as a group you know
the the wii
is definitely bigger than the me when it
comes to so so the other day
sportscenter post this on july 25th on
twitter friends hands uh the u.s men's
basketball team their first loss in the
olympics is 2004 snapping their 25 game
olympic winning streak
even fournier led the way with 28 points
in uh win tokyo 2020 right okay even
though it's 20 21. anyways at the top i
put there are two ways the us basketball
team can motivate themselves to win
number one is
love of the game number two is love
their country there's a there is
where someone on the team this is where
someone on the team has to bring up the
pride of representing the great country
the greatest country in the world this
only works if they actually believe it
now go above to the tweet above it
go right above it and see what's right
above it keep going keep going keep
going keep going keep going right there
uh luca donage went off for 48 points in
his olympic debut donation slovenia
defeat argentina 118 to 100 in the
country's first ever olympic men's
basketball game
when asked what would it mean what would
mean more to him winning an nba
championship or gold medal for his
country
his gold medal for his country he said
the gold medal for his country right so
because he's got a love and pride for
his country look it's very hard if
you're coming off of 2020
with covet and everything took place and
what are you fighting for
what does a gold medal really mean now
they're talking about hey you're going
to have to pay this much
taxes because it's gold and you're
coming back and everything is
diminishing the value of winning
for your country go to the metal leaders
go to the metal leader right now i think
u.s is at 22. i think u.s and china
china's at 21. yeah china's trying to
make a point here
kai you just have to put metal count
2020 olympics you're writing a paragraph
oh my god buddy just go back and i'm
telling you just write metal count u.s
olympics medal
count that's it this is how far he has
to go to find a medal for norway
should be all the way at the top there
you go okay so we got what oh japan's
got the most gold they just passed them
up
right now by the way that's a 30 minute
united states number one over 24
then it's china 21 then it's roc which
is
russia uh at 18. by the way armenian guy
won the gold medal yesterday in april he
had a
achilles heel he tore his achilles heel
in april
in april he tore his achilles seal he
lands can you go on twitter to show this
guy right
uh go to twitter all the way at the top
search right there check this out what's
for
just make this thing bigger so they can
hear the audio okay make it big
bring it back so there you go but you
see what's going on with the olympia you
gotta love your country man to win it
it's
i understand there's a part of it like
when you're driving
somebody to win in a sports team in
business in a company
first thing everybody thinks about is
who what's the first thing everybody
thinks about
themselves of course and it's okay
what's in it for me which is what
the rest of you natural though by the
way i don't say it in a bad way you're
right that's a form of capitalism
ayn rand agrees with you just so you
know she wrote a book about it i think
she's
something her books are going to catch
on one of these days hopefully
with you but the point is naturally
taking shots
naturally your iran but here's the point
the point is there has to be a point
where it's you
so you sit there and you say okay what's
in it for me for the rest of your life
you're going to be a gold medalist
for the rest of your life this is a one
time for the rest of your life the guy
from milwaukee bucks
said guys for the rest of your life
you're going to be called the champ
last night i had my kids watch the movie
we finished the movie you know what
movie it is the fighter
the fighter gerard comes and he says
you're watching a fighter with your kids
i see you're watching a fighter with the
kids
and my dad's sitting there my dad's like
what in the syrian what are you doing
what is the matter with you it's
actually a good uh
there's like 600 f-bombs no joke if
you've ever seen that movie it's like
[ __ ] it's nonstop is that with
christian bale
a perhaps blue ribbon baby there's so
many parts where they go into the
bedroom and she's got this uh
two-piece on i think it's a black nice
uh lingerie on yeah and they're going
i'm like
take out dylan look at me so tico's like
looking at me
but dylan's going like this
so but here's the point we watched we
watched uh we watched a
movie and there's a part i posted
because like daddy there's a lot of
cursing tico says
i want you to know something here so
there's a big difference between you and
i he says what's that
i said that's the world i grew up in i
grew up in where that's normal at night
at 10 years old my i didn't have a daddy
around me
that's normal to me that's abnormal to
you you will never experience that for
the rest of your life
the only way you can see how the reality
is for many people is by watching movies
and they do a great job explaining that
that is real for millions of people in
america but it's not real for you
we're all one decision away from ruin
the whole thing there's a scene
where he's in his corner dicky is in the
corner with mickey
mickey ward mickey's fighting for their
championship who's the fighter here
mickey ward is fighting the actor the
actor
mark wahlberg is a fighter like the
skinny yes
yes brother right so he goes to jail he
comes out and he cleans his act
and he's this corner okay and it's the
last round he comes and he says
mickey i fought sugar ray leonard
i was able to knock him out now they say
trip knock him out that's the whole
debate in the movie right he says i
never won a championship
he says do this for you first
do it for me second do it for lol
third do it for the family fourth but it
starts with doing for who
you first got to do it these olympians
many basketball players
you got to do it for you you got to do
it your family you got to do it for your
country
all are necessary to have to drive if
you don't have those three what's the
motivator so it's going to be
interesting to see what happens but
i don't know i i i wonder if this
anxiety thing is gonna go away and i
wonder if there's anything the sports
league you know olympics can do about it
or it's something that's gonna be
inevitable you gotta deal with it well
back to the original point about
olympics and simone biles is pulling out
and you talked about osaka you know they
talk about
pressure makes diamonds right and you
always see these very talented
sports figures and you wonder like what
happened to that guy how did she not
make it they were
so talented and it talent alone doesn't
make it
there's obviously your physical health
but mental health anxiety depression
and i think that we're talking about is
a good thing i mean look think about it
for the last year
during covet nobody talked about this at
least initially now i think it's a very
out there thing people you talk about
all the time that
everything was locked down the gyms are
locked down parks are locked down
especially in
certain states but they kept the liquor
stores open and what have you
and people are home with their pills and
it's depressing listen i i can
i can attest to it and i live this okay
and we train
our bodies and we train you know
our minds as far as we do as much
research as possible we watch
film but we really don't train like our
soul like and we don't train our mental
well-being and
matter of fact it's the other way they
train us that if you're not working hard
somebody else is out working you if you
didn't make it because you didn't work
hard enough
regardless of the circumstances if it's
on you
which is really nonsensical and i'll be
real you know pat was talking about like
how i'm looking better and stuff like
that
my my weight gain and all that stuff
came from hating my body
it came from actively being like you
failed me
i didn't make it to the big leagues i
wasn't good enough you know
screw it i'm just going to drink i'm
going to eat i'm going to do whatever
the hell i'm going to do everything
said i'm not happy and let me double
down on unhappy what happens is but
you're not you're not in a mental state
of being able to ascertain that you're
unhappy you're like i was repressed
for the all these years i was 225 8
body fat i did everything they told me
to do and it didn't work so here's the
question so screw it
i'm gonna go the other way and then what
ends up happening is then it becomes a
downward spiral
where then you're constantly chasing
serotonin and you're constantly chasing
the endorphins
the other big thing with guys is like
when you're an athlete you're a warrior
you got to play you got to get out there
you really don't know what kind of
injuries these people have you look at
andrew luck
like andrew luck he gave up what 50 60
70 million dollars because why
he just didn't want to take pills
anymore he woke up every morning he was
like man i need to get 10 percocets just
to get to lunch
you know and then when the game is over
when they're done with you i can't tell
you how many athletes pitchers
particularly
that they they'd get released you know
we got what do you do
we got a friend zach and then your your
body doesn't say i don't need percocet
anymore
make it give me your solution what's
your solution solution to this
is we need to destigmatize although i
hate that word we need to destigmatize
powerful people alpha people high
competitive people
getting mental health treatment the same
way you work on your body
i like that you have to work on your
mind it should be mandatory
mandatory for these people to to get
therapy once a week they should have to
do do some sort of introspective you
know reactive thing where they're not
being judged
where they're not being graded where
they're not competing
how is that not a thing already but like
behind this like the team there's team
doctors
psychiatrists how's that a thing flip it
though did you ever have a time where
you were absolutely depressed and used
partying women and you know
yeah alcohol to kind of get over a face
of your life yeah yeah you ever had that
yes okay i had that as it gets worse and
worse
by the way just so you know when you say
military when you say sports the same
thing in the military just so you know
military is a
there's a lot of depression in the
military a lot of pressure in the
military a lot of
they control you you there's a lot of
stuff that happens in the military that
is
so what do we do with it we i i've in 18
i drank
more alcohol in those 20
28 months of being in the army than i've
drank my entire life
in that two and a half years of being in
the army i drank more than i have my
entire life matter of fact i can tell
you
i drink more in a six-month run in the
army than i have my entire life
i mean that's just a fact on what
happened and what were we
escaping i mean your escape from reality
is what's your anxiety yeah
but here's here's the point this is the
part of it
this is the part of where i'm going with
you is it
like is it something where uh
uh there that that's part of the
filtering process to see who has the
goodies to handle the pressure because
let me give you an idea
for myself i run a business i've been in
sales
2013 2014 i tell you a hundred percent
for for a year plus i had anxiety
attacks every day
for your plus my palms would sweat
i would constantly go around this
anxiety okay
and one day i'm coming back i go to the
hospital two o'clock in the morning and
i'm shaking
they do my testing it was nothing the
guy's like you're just exhausted
and he's like seriously you got to take
a break you're exhausted your body said
so
put me on iv this happened like five six
times in my lifetime where i'm pushing
too hard and i realize hey a little bit
get some ivs go back at it again right
but i was running out of money i can't
go to my wife and tell her
we're running out of money she just had
a miscarriage
i've told everybody i'm starting a
business i'm down to my last penny
i'm about to lose another carrier this
is the most
difficult face i have nobody to talk to
you're what age at this point um this is
this is seven years ago about eight
years ago 13 whatever 13 is eight years
ago i'm 32
32 no 34 years old okay
now my entire life i grew up poor i
don't have any money
we've never lived in a house it's always
been in an apartment complex
it's never been like hey look at i don't
know what is
the first time i lived in a place with a
swimming pool apartment or a house
i was 30 years old i've never i don't
know what it is to have a swimming pool
right
first time i bought jordan's jays i was
32.
i i there was always this feeling of
what if we lose out what if we lose a
what if we that's the fear you're
busting your ass you're a founder you're
the guy that's first generation money
how do you make all this stuff work
you're trying to take care of everybody
please everybody make everybody happy
and then eventually it came to a point
where i tell you my my for me the savior
was
first of all i have to like the guy in
the mirror
i have to get along with that guy yeah i
have to spend the rest of my life with
him
i always give my best if i give my best
i have nothing to worry about why would
i stress that if i have something to
worry about
the judgment of christianity or
perfection i don't live by that i live
by
you know working on getting better i'm
still a christian i consider myself a
christian
but i'm somebody that's working on
developing myself i don't expect to walk
on water that pressure that kids are
raised sometimes
having to walk on water without the
ability to make mistakes put so much
unnecessary pressure on them
i think these are talks that more alphas
openly need to have
for others to say if that flipping alpha
is comfortably talking about this so i
agree with you on that side
but i got to tell you the other side
gerard it's a filtering process buddy
there's a there's a part of it that you
know jordan talked about in the last
dance he says
my dad was kicking my ass as a kid and i
was being compared to my brother and i
was challenged she says when
you're going through that moment it's so
painful yeah but you have to get through
it i
i don't disagree with you but i also
don't think like simone biles is
she she's proven herself like you know
what i'm saying so simone biles
if simone biles is having a break moment
if simone biles
you know the problem isn't that people
and there's there's going to be people
in the comments i talked about this a
lot
i've tried to make it as open as
possible the suicidal thoughts i had and
everything else
because i got through it and i want
other people that i that i've talked to
to to feel empowered to be like all
right go go get this work done man this
this [ __ ] saved my life for real
so i think what ends up happening though
is the more high functioning you are pat
the more you want to achieve the less
likely you
are to admit that you need to help
you're not the type of person
to ask for the help you're not the type
of person to be like hey man
you need some help no screw you bro i
got this i'm the man i got this all i
need to do is work harder or do this or
like it's not it's not about filtering
out
weakness it's about being able to
understand that
maybe you need some help i disagree no
no i i agree and i disagree
i agree in a sense that up until 32
33 i exactly felt that way i don't need
your help i got this let me tell you
i was a kid when i was a kid uh never in
my life have i gotten allowance from my
mom
this is something people have to know
i've never been given allowance
ever in my life never not one time jesus
not one time i've never been given
allowance okay can i get 20 bucks
i don't want to go now my dad when i
would see him every other week when my
parents got a divorce i'd get 10 bucks
and when i would come home she would say
did you get an allowance i said he gave
me 10 bucks he says we need it as a
family so i would give it to my mom
okay every week every other week one
shoe he would come and pick me up at
virgils
that would be the allowance i've never
had allowance right so for me
that there's a word called minette men
that's
if you can't really she really was a
communist oh your money is my mother
she is legit she but listen she did her
best raising us as a single mother but
she did have some
uh some beliefs that i don't agree with
uh so
so for me in that moment as a kid
i sat there and i said you know what i
don't
ever want to owe anybody anything
you know that whole thing about being in
debt is not a virtue to be in debt where
you owe somebody money slavery yeah
there's a bible says that borrow is the
slave to the lender
exactly so i said you know what screw
this so mom would go to sleep at
10 o'clock she was a 10 o'clock person
at 10 30 i acted like i'm asleep i would
go out a shopping cart in the back
i would take the shopping cart at 13 14
years old i would go
in every single and i'm not even kidding
with you i'd go to every trash
big trash and i would collect two liter
bottles and i would collect cans till
two o'clock in the morning i'd go to
albertsons
in glendale off of glendale right next
to video 2020 back in the days there's
an ihop right now i don't even know if
there's an ihop they're right off 1 34.
i would recycle i would make 10 15 20
per night come back
go to sleep wake up she had no clout a
you understand why did you have to hide
that
that what that you were trying to make
some money oh you first would have been
her mother
she didn't no no she wasn't that she
didn't want me to leave home earl
late or not she was worried because
there wasn't a father figure so she was
worried i'm going to okay she always
thought it was a
safety issue yeah she thought i was a
drug then i'm not the last person that
was
would have made a great one but i
literally was never one that uh uh
had aspirations let me tell you why you
need this heroin do you have heroin
so have you done the needs analysis uh
the point is
that feeling made me not need
people until i learned in my early 30s
if your vision is
big and you want to do something big you
have to use the word i need your help
if you can't say the word i need your
help your vision won't be because we
talk about it all the time
if you want to go fast go alone if you
want to go far go to the group go
together yeah so and and i'll tell it an
anecdotal story about about the fighter
just so that people know pat is 100 not
that they would ever think it the other
way but you're not that he's not full of
[ __ ]
i sat there and there was a conversation
going on when i first came in you don't
even probably know i was listening to
this
when he goes when he when mickey goes to
see dickie in jail
and his sons are asking why is dicky in
jail well because he got caught up in
drugs
well that makes him a bad guy that's
what their sons are saying well
not everybody who does does drugs is a
bad guy they make bad decisions this is
the conversation that's happening
and then uh i think it was dylan it was
like the people who do drugs uh
can do they ever get out well you know
it it's hard for them but if they do you
have to support them you know
and that's the conversation that's
happening right there i was like man
that's a great comment
first of all the fact that the kids at
that young age are having that
conversation with you
but i mean that you walk it like you're
talking man and you're like look
you make the they have to come back they
have to be willing to come back but if
they come back you got to be willing to
open open up your arms as well and i
think that that's
so that's kind of like my thing right
and maybe this is how we put a bow on
this whole thing it's like i want
these athletes to love america i want to
root for these athletes
i want simone biles to be able to be
like man i want to do great for this
country like
like i want us but despite our
differences to be i want that big hug
moment i want to be like you know what
lebron man
you've said some things that i really
disagree with you know i've said some
things that have probably pissed you off
we we have we we're
we're at odds with each other but man
let's come back together bro i like
watching lebron play in that usa
shirt i like watching you win i want to
i want to see you win
for us man but i just we we're so kind
of divided in this moment where
if you were an athlete supporting like i
can only imagine for a black athlete
like simone bios
she's getting pulled in this direction
she's getting pulled in that direction
you better kneel you better
put your fist up now you better not like
she's like i just want to do flips man
i just want to do flips and then you got
to do all the covet protocols and all
this other stuff and she's like
if this covered protocol stuff is for
real why am i even here i'm halfway
across the country i don't
i don't want to die in tokyo like what
am i doing here because i see where it's
a lot
part of it is also to to bring up what
you brought up the the last dance with
michael jordan and you brought up the
scene with his father and
achieving greatness but probably the
most memorable scene was
when he actually broke down in tears
remember that part when he goes
well some people think that i'm an
[ __ ] or think that i'm a tyrant
but i just want you know that's you yeah
because you've never won anything before
yeah
and you know that's what i needed to do
for to get my teammates to win it's a
team sport talking team usa or whatever
yeah
and that's what i needed to do so
if you've never done it don't come at me
like that yeah break
bro cliche as it is they're still humans
man just cause they look like
superhumans act like
humans they're still humans right and
you know like that's
you know i don't i don't have an answer
we're making there's a lot of people
like stephen a smith like making a hell
of a lot of money
they make a whole lot of money doing
nothing but playing monday morning
quarterback on every single decision
somebody makes
it and just raising the pressure on
people i think they should have a
compensation package
that's based on accuracy if you're
calling a guy would be fired okay
same with fox news pat however msnbc put
them all on dude
i'm talking about sports but if you want
to get politics too
you should have a compensation package
based on
accuracy and predictions yeah so when
charles barkley is like i guarantee
that the suns are going to win the
finals but to them but but
that to me no barclays entertainment
steven a is not entertainment steven a
is journalism and steven a's a different
story so for example
when you're talking about a person on
cnn
claims they're a journalist but they're
giving their bias nonstop
it's a propaganda very simple is what
you're doing if a person on msnbc claims
they're then
they're pitching whatever they're
pitching you ain't know a journalist
your propaganda same goes with fox when
somebody gets up there and says what
they say
so having a conversation with uh um
david harris jr i gave a talk a couple
days ago
in where was i at where was uh where was
that where was that dallas
dallas i gave a talk in dallas for this
uh guy who's running this
event called eight percent nation cody
had a chance to meet him his wife his
family liked him a lot a lot and and
he had this partner six nine guy you can
tell there was a lot of strong values
there
david harris jr sent me a message hey
you're in dallas assignment so you come
down he comes down we start talking
hang out on the back it's me himself
matt zappala curtis hitman mario
samville we're seeing having a
conversation together and
uh he says why do you think sean hannity
gave that vaccination message at the end
on fox the other day
i said what do you mean it says do you
think it's a you know murdock you think
it's fox
i said there's only one person that can
make hannity give a message of
vaccination
on tv only one person ain't his wife
tony
it is only trump donald trump yeah okay
and the only reason that message is
being said is because the
world maybe doesn't know that uh in
april trump and his wife got
the covet vaccine quietly then when he
got it done so hannity
is given that message and i said this is
my speculation i may be wrong
my speculation is the fact that trump
is already strategizing his run and he's
already starting to campaign
and the one thing he doesn't want the
left to hold over him is the fact that
he's an
anti-vaxx community representing
conservatives and he has to start off by
the biggest people on the right such as
hannity
to start saying if you think it's good
go take it just makes you talk to the
experts etc etc
right now 99 chance trump is running
there's no question i'm at 100. yeah i'm
not at home
what else is he doing i'm not at 100 is
because of a couple of the things that
you know i was told but uh 99
i think he's how old is that he's going
to be like what 77
who's david harris jr by the way david
harris jr is a guy
that's a black conservative uh one of
these guys that's got a few hundred
million very very popular
incredible incredible communicator yeah
incredible communicator and got a great
story
married 27 years family guy beautiful
family two beautiful i mean just a
beautiful
family's got there married 27 years how
old is he he's 46
yeah mary 27. okay david you got to take
it easy how long was your marriage
a couple couple minutes so so anyway so
let's
you guys want to get into a couple of
stories let's get to a couple of sources
we've already touched up all olympics
why don't we get into it
tokyo olympics opening draws 16.7
million u.s
tv viewers 33-year low that's
pretty low by the way to say 33 year low
that's a long time nbc broadcasted tokyo
olympics
opening uh ceremony for only 16.7
million viewers the smallest television
audience for the last 33 years
uh it declined 37 from 2016 when 26.5
million people watched the rio de
janeiro
games open and 59 down from 2012
when 40.7 million people watched the
london ceremony was the lowest audience
for the opening since 1980 at soul games
which attracted 22.7 million tv viewers
nbc universal which paid 7.65 billion
dollars
to extend its us broadcast right for the
olympics through 2032 plans
to air an unprecedented seven hours of
olympic coverage across
multiple television networks and peacock
streaming services is what they're
saying
so uh what are your thoughts about that
for being now what is the reason for it
when you watch some of these matches
there's nobody in the audience is it
because
of covet is it lack of interest is it
you're saying in japan
yeah why are why is the tv viewership in
u.s so low
well you know they say when you lose one
sense the other senses
get you know stronger if you lose your
sense of sight your sense of of hearing
gets stronger well when the rich lost
their sense of humor their sense of
self importance got stronger and this is
just non-stop
preaching it's not there's nothing fun
about any of this have you watched any
of this
there's nothing fun there's no more fun
in sports there's no more
fun in television like even in the even
in the nfl draft did you watch the nfl
draft
it was not what this kid did in college
it was well he comes from the poorest
neighborhood in the poorest state and
his mother had 18
jobs a day and it's okay you can root
for this kid
he's not one of these rich kids it's
okay it's it's okay he's gonna be a
multi-millionaire in the nfl
they're doing the same thing they're
like i don't care how bad everybody had
it i care
are you awesome at your sport i i came
here to see excellence
i came here to see absolute the pinnacle
of human achievement and politics have
just
infiltrated this entire thing there are
judokas
like my father was an olympic alternate
in judo i watched judo
all right i like judo i was a judoka and
these dudes won't
fight the israeli champion they won't
they're literally pulling out of the
olympics
because they refuse for political
reasons to get in the ring i won't i
won't touch
that it was uh the first one was i think
i don't i don't want to get it wrong i
believe it was azerbaijan and algeria
are those the two i don't want to get it
wrong but they they literally pulled out
because they they wouldn't stand on the
same mat with
israeli and the whole pull up that story
the whole point of the olympics by the
way for people that know the history of
the olympics
it came together as the it was the
original united nations
in greece there were so many warring
city-states that they were like look
instead of us killing tens of thousands
of each other like every year why don't
we just have these games and we'll
wrestle naked and
we'll meet each other have some wine
it'll be cool to be told what you just
did is what needs to be told
what should you say is what needs to be
told the wrestling naked party that's
the part that's it's
it's just a lot of eye contact the
coming together part yes what no what
no no not the coming together but what
needs to be told is
when a marriage is in a bad place you
have to remind them why did you guys
date in the first place
what brought you guys together there's a
right before divorce that's a
conversation
america needs to know history of why
olympics
is the olympics so is this one you're
talking about a a second judoka pulls
out of the olympics an apparent move to
avoid
facing israeli sudans muhammad abba
dalar soul skips bout with tohar batpo
who wins next fight but loses metal
chance later athlete is a no-show
despite
cartoon signing abraham accords with
israel the second number i'm going to go
a little lower
suspended for doing the same but paul
was listed as no competitor in the
lessons
73 olympic officials that didn't show to
facebook
in their route despite weighing in about
early international judo federation
didn't immediately announce the reason
if i'm just going to give him another
response
okay so you know here's my question yeah
is that his decision or are there people
behind this
point pulling strings that's a good
question there's no way we can have one
of our
athletes lose to an israeli or even
you're right israeli
so it's not a good look for us so we're
gonna make a political stance here
and we're not gonna fight this guy's
been training his whole life now he's
about to win the gold or like sorry
buddy have a seat what but take that
exactly what you said is right now
extrapolate that out
right you think you think multiple
sports yeah like do you think lebron
james is coming up with like
with minister farrakhan's words on his
own or do you think somebody from the
nation of islam is like you know what
you should say something like this
like these people have infiltrated the
highest levels of our culture
you think simone biles is backing out
because the the you know
the gymnastics aspect of this is the
pressure she can't handle of course it's
not
she's the best gymnast possibly of all
time this is second hat to her it's
probably what she loves more than
anything in the world
the pressure of being pulled in
different directions by these incredibly
powerful people
is what she's going like you know what
screw it i'm not here to be your mascot
i'm not here to be the mascot of your
social action
i'm not here to be the mascot of this
side or that side i just want to perform
and these dudes out here
they again four years of competition to
get to the highest level
and now you have somebody and because of
political differences you're not going
to compete
but let me see why why is guys why is
viewership down
why is viewership in u.s down that's
look i think a part of it
is you know people just like what you
said about the nba why was the viewer
viewer viewership up they took all the
political stuff away from it they said
listen just come here enjoy sports
right i think that's obviously a factor
here in the olympics and i think also a
part of it
we all feel for the athletes we're all
rooting for the athletes sure i think
lingering maybe this is for me it's my
opinion
i'm not that interested in olympics for
whatever reason
because i think that the committees and
whoever's putting everything together is
just corrupt
when i think of the olympics i think of
corruption i do
how do these countries get it they built
listen you hear these stories
about china building these ridiculous
stadiums
and then after the olympics they're gone
they don't even use the average person
in america is not watching olympics
because they think the judges are
corrupt
judges the overall olympic committees
the selection the way that they pick the
cities
the doping i'm just saying outcomes
razor i just think it's not fun anymore
they don't know how to create a fun
product i don't know i have my okay you
don't think the olympics is corrupt
at all the audience by the way i won't
actually hear you guys why do you
kai why do you think i want to know if
you guys do you guys have any opinions
on this or not at all
it has to be if you haven't if it's
different than what they said say it if
not
i have one i think um a big one is
obviously what you guys have mentioned
uh in terms of that second one is the
fact that the whole last year is it
happening
is it not oh [ __ ] it happens tomorrow
wait it actually started okay so i think
that is a big open field
scheduling yes okay schedule not enough
good marketing yes
and just confusion of like because i saw
articles still the week of
it could still be canceled like all
right is it going on is it not
the other part second part which also i
think is a big part uh
they're cur japan is currently 13 hours
ahead so the schedule they're competing
in the middle of the night so yeah but
china was the same yeah
that's not as big but i think the
biggest one is the fact that they were
uh like is it happening is it being
canceled okay what do you guys think
anything different or no
david uh i just yeah i never really had
much interest in the olympics i think
it's a historic event
then it's a no-brainer for you like it's
a non-issue for you like who cares
okay even the soccer right now i will
say as it gets down to more of the
finals
viewership is going to go the kabuki
theater bothers me where it's like okay
everybody's wearing a mask but then the
mask is down over here and then now they
got to go compete face to face with each
other it's like
it's just too much like safety theater
for me i just
i don't feel like i'm watching a
competition i feel like i'm watching
propaganda i'm trying to see if that's
how
the average viewer feels the way
you do so there is how i feel there's
how you feel then there's
the average american that's like just
not watching it why so you're saying
because of the committee
you're saying because of the you know
it's not fun anymore it's just too
politicized
uh i i i don't know i'm gonna read you
the story here you tell me if there's
this
angle here that could be taking place so
go to page eight
if you go to page eight all the way at
the bottom on page eight okay
americans optimism about countries
direction over the next year drops
nearly 20 points since may
and may a little more than a third worm
pessimistic now it's a majority
55 percent are pessimistic versus a
third
as biden completes his first hundred
days in office the country and
optimistic about the countries in the
coming year
but now just after hitting six month
mark america's optimism about the
erection country has plummeted nearly 20
points a new abc poll
finds the decline in optimism has
occurred across abroad amongst democrats
republicans and independents optimism is
down 20 points amongst democrats and
republicans
down 26 points amongst independents so
this isn't a republican hit piece
on biden this is a left right center it
is
it likely reflects the growing concerns
that lockdown could be reinstated
already vaccinated americans could near
both
the booster shot as a highly contagious
delta variant now it's estimated to
account for 83 percent of all new
coronavirus cases in the united states
fewer than 4 in 10 americans approve of
the president's handling of the
immigration immigration
and the situation at the u.s mexico
border crime and gun violence okay
um i don't know do
does somebody care to watch somebody
win if you no longer have pride in them
i don't know
i i don't have pride in the lakers
because of what they keep
talking about so guess what i did i
could care less about wanting you know
how
i may be one of the biggest laker fans
in the world like i really could
have no pride in watching anything the
lakers are doing has the american
the basic american citizen not not i'm
talking about the big which is
most america as a basic american citizen
just sat there and said honestly
listen man i don't know if i love
america like i used to
you guys don't even talk about this the
greatest country in the world i'm
watching the news
more articles coming out whether america
is the greatest country anymore or not
you're
so you know the power affirmations we
talked about this on the tour
do you know the jane elliott story uh uh
the perf
the teacher third grade teacher in 1964
what she did
no okay do you know the jane elliott
story kai or no the jane elliott story
let me tell you jane elliott's story
pull up the jane elliott story
martin luther king dies okay
martin luther king dies day after martin
luther king dies this teacher named jane
elliott
does an exercise for the third graders
here's what she does okay
she goes and she says day one
she says students uh major research just
came and i want to give you guys the
research here what's the research
teacher what's the research teacher
here's a research um research has shown
that blue-eyed people are smarter
stronger and have better privileges
and deserve a better life than brown
eyed people oh my goodness
and the students like what so yep
blue-eyed people are smarter stronger
and are more privileged
than brown-eyed people this students
aren't going to third graders it's not
like it's college or high school
third grade where's this going oh my god
eight years old so all of a sudden
one of the blue eyed kid is talking to
the brown eyed kid and is asking a
question about math and the brown one
kid gets the answer wrong or whatever
the question he was asking
and the blue eyed kid says oh you're
brown eyed
makes sense okay so the brown eyed kid
comes and pushes
shoves the blue eye kid and a fight
breaks out right
so the teacher says it's okay we're done
today you guys go home we'll come back
tomorrow tomorrow
everybody comes to school and the
teacher says i made a mistake
research came back and they said it's
actually the brown night
kids that are smarter stronger and more
privileged than the blue-eyed people
and it's true i'm sorry my apologies i
made the mistake
brown-eyed kids are smarter stronger and
more privileged than blue-eyed kids
and everybody's like what the blue-eyed
kids are devastated
heartbroken and the brown eyed kids are
like i told you
part of the broad night community right
and then
all of a sudden a debate starts taking
place and they're going back and forth
kids and one the brown eyed kid says
you're a bluey
you don't know what you're talking about
so the word bluey gets a label
with blue-eyed kids then the next day
three days later the teacher comes out
and says kids
i've lied neither blue-eyed or
brown-eyed people have any privileges
you're messing with my head teacher
you're not stronger you're not smarter
very much
you're not nobody cares you have to go
earn
your privileges you have to go earn all
of that
for her if she would have done that
today she should be in jail by the way
by the way she did this a day after mlk
assassination
think about the optics and the timing of
how brave
this teacher is very impressive think
about the anxiety levels in the country
that's a true education what i'm trying
to go ahead kai
yeah but also the other thing is this
was done in like the far
north so there was a racial dispute yeah
yeah yeah but this is coming from a
bluey brother
she would also tell them when they were
fighting like oh it's because he's a
blue
so she'd feed into that she's trying to
she was the original fake news but
they would allow her to she was doing
this obviously validated
what republicans and democrats and the
mainstream media is doing today
she validated the point so you know what
happens here here's a point
why are you going to love america what
do i love what is america to love today
what what what is it when you ask
somebody like i asked a question do you
love america
you ask a regular person like you know
what you're not going the streets mm-hmm
you know what i shouldn't do that
you know what you should do about it i
want you to do that i will i want you to
go and say
do you love america and let them say set
it up okay you guys going to miami
do you love america and they say what
yes or no no matter what they say guess
what the next question is
why yeah okay no i hate america why
i love america why see who's traveled
and who has yeah
i'll tell you anthony bourdain you know
had a great great quote and said like
to to know america is to love her and
it's the truth man like
we've all traveled we've all been very
lucky to have traveled this whole
country and there's no way that you
could travel this country
and just not be like man this is a great
place place is a great place full of
great people and it's not perfect but
it's great
and it's trying to be better and we're
going through growing pains
and that's why i probably you know i
hate the commies more than anything else
because
you know especially the upper middle
class comedy is like it's not perfect
burn it down and it's like bro we're
doing pretty good here
we're not perfect but we're trying and
every every
person you meet almost every person
outside of an incredibly small outlier
wants them and their neighbors and their
neighbors families to be successful and
one of
the great things about kovid that never
gets talked about
is every single person with no questions
asked really
almost almost every human being was
willing to shut down their business was
willing to shutter themselves in their
house
was willing to shut down their lives
completely because they thought it would
make their community safer
now as time roar on and it was six
months eight months ten months and there
was a ton of mixed messages and then we
realized okay there's there's political
motivations behind this
you started getting serious pushback as
you should have i was ready to throw the
tea in the harbor and
i was waiting for the booga boys to come
with me but
the in the beginning every single one of
us
really showed our love for country and
nation i believe that we showed our love
for community first few months
because we shut it down because we we
wanted to keep each other six weeks guys
six weeks yeah
yeah yeah 15 days to flatten the curve
right so
part of this anxiety that i feel and
that a lot of people feel
is we were lied to now
i feel like i love the country i hate
our government
and i'm able to make those two that i'm
able to distinguish between the two
i hate our federal government with every
fiber of my being
i hate our federal government but i love
the people of the united states of
america
explain the two so so explain what part
of the government you hate
i hate the federal government i hate
what our federal government has become
i hate the the the uh the panopticon
that we're living in i hate the
the the security state that we've given
our lives to i think
uh you know people have been saying this
for 20 years
and they've been wait we've been waiting
and waiting we are seeing
the ramifications of the patriot act we
are seeing today we are living in the
fallout from the patriot act we are
living in the fallout from bush cheney
rumsfeld
and the the the way that our life is
being infringed upon
and now the the the elites the
quote-unquote elites they're saying
the quiet parts out loud and this ivy
league cabal
of you know the entrenched powers that
are always going to be
in power um you know the fact that that
they're so beholden they look
i said it and i've said it before and
and maybe it sounds salacious but this
is the truth and i believe it to be the
truth
they had a chance to choose between the
united states and china and they chose
china
and that's just the truth of it they did
not choose us they have not chose their
citizens
they have not chose the the people down
here at the ground floor you saw it in
washington dc over the weekend
when they erased cuba libre off the
street they erased it off the street
these are people fighting tyranny real
tyranny real tyranny
and they erased it off the street
because it was going to incite hate you
pulled that up guy
but any any communist fist whether it's
black lives matter or not forget the
black lives matter it's the communist
fist
that commie fist is gonna stay on the dc
streets forever sure
rodolfo ramirez just said if you don't
hate the government you have you haven't
worked for the government yeah
exactly if you don't take the
government's line and you're just not
paying attention
talk about hitting the government i i
have a note here because we have a
couple stories on cuba a couple stories
on iran
obviously china and i said it's
important to remember the people are not
the governments go back of these
countries
and you would talk i'm sure we're going
to talk about what's going on in iran
we're talking about cuba
the people are the people the government
are not the people like we talked about
with general spalding that what
six percent of china is part of the ccp
so
i hear you on that um
do you think our government represents
us the people right now do you think our
federal government
this administration basically if you if
you look at the approval ratings for
what's going on in congress it's
disastrously low and it's getting lower
so no i think i think you know
don't i mean trump was the fascist trump
was the dictator but now we have
people saying they're going to go door
to door kick down your door
yeah drag you out that's all rhetoric no
no this is that's actually this is cuomo
yesterday andrew cuomo in new york state
yes that's your state that's your
question i don't know anything about
that that's not happening
you can google actually pull that up are
you sure you haven't seen what cuomo
said yesterday
did you hear what he said he would kick
down the door put you in a car
and get you jabbed in your arm that's
good okay let's see what cuomo has to
say
so no it's an hour and 18 minutes you
need to find one that's like 30 seconds
this is the guy who was a leading
candidate for the next president he was
going to be your president
yeah so click on watch what he says yeah
there you go
we're talking about people that are
reading our text messages reading our
emails they're going to come to our
house and and you know
hit us with experimental medication
happened right after 9 11. and there was
overreach obviously because there was
shock and discussion what happened in
911 and then
just like we learned about with taxes
when pat did his tax episode
it's just temporary it's just temporary
and then what happens with the taxes pat
it keeps going and keeps going and then
i i guess this is
my issue why i keep picking on democrats
specifically especially in my family is
i know a lot of republicans who left the
republican party and became libertarians
or just became independents or flat out
never or
they're called rhinos now because they
said this patriot act is [ __ ]
we should never be in iran we should not
we should never be in afghanistan we
should never be in iraq
right off the bat they said this this
rumsfeld cheney stuff is nonsense
all right now he died recently yeah he
did like which you know weeks ago
yeah not not that i dance on anybody's
grade but the world's a better place
without donald rumsfeld that's for sure
so then i don't even feel controversial
saying that we should have slingshot him
into the sun years ago
but the the cheney faction is now the
biden faction
and that's never admitted by democrats
it's never admitted that those guys
met right that's the establishment it's
the establishment man
so when when we talk about that do they
have our best
look i i i ascribe to something that
that's a pretty um
you like to talk about my extremist
views of of freedom and letting people
be
a volunteer society but i i do believe
we are tribal people i believe we're
naturally tribal that's why i think it's
so
important for us to promote
individualism and iron rand
and to promote the in the beauty of the
individual because we are tribal we're
naturally tribal but that being said
we are always looking for a chief we're
always looking for a tribal chief i
ascribe to what's called the great man
theory it could be a woman it could be a
man
but we need more than ever in in my
lifetime
i cannot think of a time that we were
more devoid of leadership
that we did not have somebody that we
can look to and say you know what
this is somebody that knows well you had
your boy donald trump for four years
i was there wait he's not my boy donald
trump was not my boy
did i vote for donald trump two thousand
i don't know i'm asking him did i vote
donald trump 2000 uh 2012.
all right here we go 2016. i voted for
donald trump in 2020
because this this walking talking zombie
that is
you know weakened at bernie's biden that
they keep propping up i mean he saw the
strings the others
yeah i mean how long until uh kumala
harris finishes off the job here man but
i mean the
listen i didn't i didn't mind what trump
did i i
really really really really loathe the
tactics the democrats
did to to gain power in 2020. the fact
that you know just the lying the
gaslighting talking about the insurgency
after they burnt down the country for a
summer it's nonsensical
it's nonsensical all right and if we're
not able to live that's again i'm gonna
say it for the third podcast in a row
that's why i love russell brand
the bill maher had another great one
this weekend that the left refuses to
ever admit progress
uh you know rogan like these guys who
are on the left
are saying enough enough already and
that's that's
it's got to come from there can't come
from the outside
i agree with you on that i say that
every show that you it needs to come
from
inside like where's the phone call
coming from inside the house
yeah it's exactly what it is
let's talk about what happened with the
nfl it's a bit of a strange story here
and
extreme at the highest level and i
thought to find unvaccinated players
fourteen thousand six hundred fifty
dollars for any violation of kobe 19
protocols
and espn stories spotlight was put on
the punishment
after report that tampa bay buccaneers
coach bruce arians would find a player
14 000
on the spot every time he isn't wearing
a mask or is breaking a protocol this
led to some sp
to speculate that aryans was insinuating
instituting the
this fine as his own personal rule nfl
policy aryans told espn is in
text message league rules league
spokesperson brian mccarthy confirmed to
espn that arianes was correct in his
understanding of the nfl's rule
aryans said the bucks will have close to
85 percent of players fully vaccinated
by final cut downs
some players have voice resistance to
the vaccine
however deandre hopkins we already know
what he said he says he doesn't want to
do it he took his
tweet down then he put freedom then he
said niners in the nfl
then a minnesota vikings assistant coach
just said i'm done i'm not doing it
that's not taking a blind coach in the
nfl the best offensive line coach in the
nfl said i'm done
beasley the other day but if you can
bring up kai i i wish this had a little
bit more details about nfl's
guidelines because the way this works is
if because of you
they have to suspend or cancel a game
you will take the l you'll get a loss
but they will take money of salary of
all players involved in that game your
team and their team away
yeah period so meaning if you're
expected to make eight hundred thousand
dollars that game it's gone yeah
so you're only playing 16 games that
money 18 games this year that money is
gone
right so nfo's obviously made it a point
that they're going extremely
uh uh extreme measures with this whether
this by the way fauci comes out and
fouchy they asked them they said what do
you think about what the nfl is doing it
says
well the nfl is making it very obvious
that they're sending a strong message to
the players that they better take the
vaccine seriously
is what he said so now the question
becomes one
is that the right way approach this and
two will nba nhl and mlb follow
i don't know i don't know the other
sports but let me address this isn't we
talked about bruce arians because
you know he's the head coach of the
tampa bay bucks they won the super bowl
this is not a bruce aryan story kai if
you scroll up
this is a hundred percent this guy right
here roger goodell like if you talk
about the main sports in the united
states and you ask people
what sport is most concerned about the
money
most people would say the nfl i think i
feel like the nfl is just a cash crab
all they care about is the money and
this is just follow the money
so this is not a safety issue i mean for
the most part obviously it is a little
bit this isn't a covet thing
this is a don't [ __ ] with our money and
if you
and your opinions get in the way of our
multi-billion dollar industry
we're going to take that money out of
your pocket fill in the blank
so the nfl you know they say it stands
for
not for long if you want to do your own
thing and get in the way of our money
you won't be having money not for long
so this is just an ftm follow the money
thing
and roger goodell he runs this with a
tight ship
and i think this is a straight up just a
money grab and they don't want any
individual cole beasley the andre
hopkins bruce aryans
who cares to get in the way of their
billion dollar industry
quite simple we have a few uh we got a
few nfl players
that follow this shout out to you guys
that follow this podcast love you guys
appreciate you guys listening
hit us in the dms and stuff like that
gave us some good insight on this man
really really
shout out to y'all but my biggest
takeaway from them
wasn't even the this is the societal
thing right like
the what whether you're gonna bend the
knee and and do what you're what your
business and your boss tell you to do
or you're gonna like this is a fight
this is an obedience test more than
anything else
what they're mad about isn't necessarily
the the
what the league is doing they're so mad
at the nfl pa
they think the nfl pa is so useless at
defending them at fighting the nfl they
think the
the nfl pa and d marie smith who runs it
are so so useless they're so bad at
their job
so pat if you were running the nflpa
if you were running the the the labor
side
of this nfl partnership all right and
you represented 800 players against 32
owners
how would you handle this situation so
first of all
i think the nfl is so tied to
having to please the government uh i
think it's tied to it because
to take a position like this this is a
very extreme position to take like this
is almost
worse than a position the government has
taken like
let me kind of give you an example what
this means so this means
if i were let's bring it to a regular
job forget sports bring you to a job
so if you work at a company and you went
to
chipotle you came back you got
coveted from a guy at chipotle that
maybe wasn't quarantining
you come to the office 17 people end up
getting coveted from you
you have to go to the house for two
weeks and can't work for two weeks
that means the company is taking away
your salary for two weeks
and the other 12 uh 14 you know however
many people that got covered as well for
two weeks
and suspending you and finding them for
you being irresponsible everybody else
also takes a hit that's what that's what
this is essentially about so if you
bring it to a company
that's what this is so you mean to tell
me you're gonna dictate
my uh uh unpaid salary
this is so extreme it's concerning to me
so
the position again goes back to why i
have a hard time with the product of the
mba until this playoffs
when i saw the playoff run when lebron
was out when i said kd's out kyrie is
out i'm like okay
hopefully giannis is not going to bring
in politics hopefully booker's just
going to play ball
hopefully trey young is not already you
know as a 22 year old guy he's not yet
ingrained with
you better or else and it was a great
playoff series that we got a chance to
watch right there wasn't any part of it
but
i think the direction they're going
right now it's you have one choice
you either have to be pro vaccine
or if you're not you're going to pay a
fine war fine for it
that's like the nfl is being a doctor
all of a sudden yeah that's as if the
nfl
i think they're doing it well again it
went back to the government
because you want to be aligned with the
government because the last thing you
want is sanctions regulation additional
things that the government may come
look think about it this way this isn't
a big money
let me let me guys let me simplify let's
let's
let's play the conspiracy game can we
play it let's just let's just
our favorite games
let's play the conspiracy game you ready
for a conspiracy game okay
every industry has something they fear
that can put them out of business
okay all right so for example what does
china fear does china
want uh elon musk to go out there in the
satellite and create free internet for
everybody
does any communistic nation want free
china wants control
we know that do you think iran wants
free internet for all their people
whether people can go on youtube and
facebook no okay
so go think about what uh the dnc fears
what does the the rnc fear okay
what does trump fear what is biden fear
what does obama fear what is
you know jillian maxwell fear what does
everybody fear
what is the number one fear on nfl's
mind number one fear on nfl's mind
up until of it it was concussions
exactly so go to concussions yeah so
when concussions the movie came out by
uh will smith it got everybody thinking
about it right do you know how many
parents
jennifer doesn't want dylan to play
football
so the product of football is sitting
there saying this cannot get serious
long term
because if it does guess what the
ramifications to the game
to the product of football could be big
who is the only organization that can
treat the nfl the way they treat
facebook google
youtube all of those guys federal
government the federal government if the
federal government government targets
the nfl and says hey
nfl roger goodell just want to let you
know i
we're not threatening or anything but we
just want you to be a good vaccine
citizen
and because we want to make sure that
story of concussions doesn't come back
up we're going to help we're going to
protect
that's that's the again what are your
thoughts on predator drones
by the way this is just a game we just
played yeah
but you can take this game and think the
next question you got to ask yourself
was a following you know what the next
question you ask yourself here's the
next question you gotta ask yourself
here's the next question you gotta ask
yourself
and by the way if you're watching this
i'm actually curious to know what you
say about this
zero two hundred give me your percentage
what percentage do you say
that conversation has been had
what percentage so thousand what's that
what's the percentage
like you know like you know john perkins
who was the economic hit man that goes
to other countries saying
you better allow us to build over here
and take the oil or else we're going to
ruin your economy
because we have ways of doing it that
was his job and i dare you to play
against us we don't play nice yeah i'm
the guy that's coming telling you this
do you think there's somebody like that
that went to the nfl and said if you do
anything that's anti-vaxx
we're going to bring you down and wait
zero to 100 000 to 100.
a thousand it's actually higher than uh
the conspiracy uh
typical thing what do you think it is
give me a percentage i would say there's
a
higher than 50 percent chance that
conversation has that chance i'm going
to say it's 30 percent
i'm actually not even going there i'm
not i'm not 100 i'm not i'm not at all
about 30 ten thousand percent
thousands yeah all i'm saying to you is
i'm speculating
yeah that that because the only way a
person again
hannity all of a sudden made an extreme
position which is what you should go get
the vaccine to protect your family
what are you talking about nfl just made
an extreme position
who who you fear to make an extreme
position like that i don't know about
that you know so for me you know
the moment so what can the government
dangle over them you want this
little concussion thing to come back out
not about that what is it
are you kidding me do you know how much
money they get from the duke the doj is
their biggest average do you think it's
a dod i'm sorry
the dod is their biggest defense yeah
advertiser
yeah the jets flying over every game
everything do you do
i don't even think that's what it is but
i don't even think it's a dod part do
you do you think
what's a look every time we watch tv and
we see mark
zuckerberg they're answering questions
to congressman is that a good look for
him
do you think it's a good look when you
see the ceo of google there or see
twitter
saying hey goodell you don't want to
come in front of us ever again right you
they're going to say if you want to be
sitting in front of congress grilling
you about what you're doing about
concussions 24
7. we will make your life a living
that's like when congress went after
baseball
steroids okay so i get that on gadell's
part
i'm going back to the nfl pa where are
they at here like okay they they can do
that all they want cadell can do that
nflp what are you talking about they got
to be on the plane they got to be on the
side of the planet
dude do you know dude just dm to me dude
just dm to me yeah i'm not going to say
this 11 year nfl player all right says
we have to sign away our hipaa
our hippa rights when we go to the
combine
so we're not allowed to we're not
allowed to to have any sort of medical
privacy
well he said it's cause of gambling so
if i have a broken leg
the whole the whole world gets to know i
have a broken leg and the other team can
target my leg
right there i'm not an injury reporter
i'm not allowed privacy no you asked me
a question about
players association why wouldn't here's
my reason for players association
the hell are you talking about the
bigger the contract i get
is the more money you're making the
bigger the product nfl makes the bigger
the money and flpa you want to make more
money
you got to make sure we don't get
holding to your players aren't you
there's a lot of players that are saying
i i've got enough
you actually think that's how this thing
works when they're sitting there you you
actually think nflpa is sitting there
only thinking about the health of
they're going to sit there and they're
going to say the following what if it's
not they need new people in the nflpa
well
they need new people in every most
positions they need new people we got
people in the government that's sitting
there
making decisions for others that they're
not making decisions for others they're
making decisions for their reelection
that's all they're thinking about
how many people do you have that's under
20th term i mean obviously i'm being
sarcastic 20 a term but you get what i'm
saying
when there are people that are just
going on their terms they're not doing
it for the people
all i'm saying to you is money's going
to talk
and they're sitting there saying what
percentage will take the vaccine no
problem 87
cares about the 13 guys let's just let's
just move on who cares about the 13
let's move on again this is a conspiracy
theory
i thought 30. you say i said it's
actually pretty likely yeah it's like
but that's still
that's still again anytime those
questions ftm follow the money they
don't want this 13 percent
coming after the 87 listen i was i told
the story to gerard the other day
i said here's what's happening right now
i'm 16 years old
we're sitting around a bunch of friends
and everybody for the
15 years i'm in wilson junior house 14
years old we're sitting around
first kid comes up this is the first
time i was exposed to smoking weed
hey here guys try some of this what is
it everybody smokes a tupac smokes it
we're big tupac guys look okay i'll try
some wheat guy tries the guy tries a guy
tries it
everybody tries it then it comes to me
pat here you go i said i'm good
why not i'm good i don't want to smoke
it so i said i'm good i don't want to
smoke it
three laughed two were quiet two came
afterwards to find out why
what's the point here's a point yeah the
dissenter is the issue
here's the point the people that are not
saying no to this i guarantee you
they're being text message they're
getting calls oh yeah
they're calling them and dm and say can
we talk about this why didn't you take
it
you're pretty smart guy why'd you say no
the small community that is saying no
people are going to ask
here's the strangest thing about this
entire situation here
a friend of mine sent me a message okay
and he said pat i gotta tell you i don't
give a [ __ ] about taking a vaccine
hell i would take the vaccine in a
heartbeat i would take the vaccine
what i have a problem with is the fact
that it's forced upon
me taking it that's my problem i'm an
alpha
don't force me to take the vaccine give
me the options
give me the out i'll take it versus
making me feel like an
idiot if i don't want to take it it's
actually not a good marketing tactic
dictators do that countries like iran do
that a few other countries in the past
did that that we know about one of them
was in europe i think it starts with the
letter g
germany did things like that where they
told you you better do it or else
now america is doing this what are we
talking about here yeah yeah it's it's
it's
social did you see the social score
stuff with paypal too that
that gets me what was that social school
repayment so you know china has that
social score okay
all right where they basically implement
so people that don't know like what are
the big issues with communism right no
no private property
you get a house quote unquote from the
bank of china and then the bank decides
that's not your house anymore your
social score is too low it's our house
now they just take it back
it's it's there's so the social score is
like you're posting the wrong things if
you're
if somebody if somebody said that you're
you're having this conversation that
that
you know is uh you know counter counter
to party lines
they can it's like an obedience score
yes it's a 100 percent obedient score
but
with with the with the ramifications
being
really i got to tell you your obedience
score is very low it is we're going to
not stop i got to tell you i got to know
your heart
i will die on the vine disobedient to
the day i really don't care
to hell with them we will go out
swinging and i'm fine with it
but now paypal is doing that as well
and they're working with government
officials
to root out extremist organizations and
people who profit and misinformation
so the government is not our government
who operates almost is almost
exclusively in misinformation
is working with a private company who
handles
billions of dollars in transactions
every minute
and they're going to root out extremism
and misinformation which is why i got i
got a push back on guys like you great
dude
got to know you you're awesome but when
you call normal people insurgents
you're you're feeding into that well
they're extremists of course they should
have their transactions taken away
number one that's why they called to
paypal mafia number two are you actually
trying to say that january 6 was just
nice people hanging out at the you think
january 6 was was actually a coup
i don't know if it was a coup but those
were insurgents anyway we don't need to
go there
wait a minute insurgent means a coup so
do you think that was a coup
do i think they were actually going to
take over the government
and no they were they were trying to
stop it's called protesting
it was insurgent is a coup so there's a
big difference if you want to say
they're digesting
whatever you want to do
this is very that's not a good very
important it's never a good look to
defend those people
it's very very important look it's not a
good look to defend
riders that are ruining businesses and i
don't think you supported that i agree
but but you have to realize there's a
big difference between calling me an
[ __ ] and calling me a con man there's
a big difference
i'm even worse than domestic terrorist
what i'm trying to tell you is you call
somebody an [ __ ]
okay he's an [ __ ] cool you call him a
con man there's a big difference
true words matter yeah so what i'm
trying what i'm trying to tell you is
there's a difference between saying
those guys were rioting protesting
looters
okay yeah you're right insurgents cool
come on man
they said it so there's their words have
fair enough but don't pretend they were
just good people
i on what they did but i think they were
upset with the election they went out
there and they did what the other
protesters were yeah
my biggest problem that it was all
antifa
it was all blm dressed up as they all
bought maga hats that
the key is is that that rhetoric is now
being weaponized
in very very appreciable ways that's why
all of us all of us down here at the
ground level we have to band together
all of us down here at the ground level
have to band together not not agree with
one another we just have to agree
in the reality of situations i said
right now january 6 pad wasn't good a
police officer died like do you think
we're saying it was good like again
that's the kind of stuff do you
do you think the writing and protesting
in the streets was good when people died
when
cops got shot up you think that's good
when when folks on the other side did it
like really do you think when i lived in
dallas five miles away from my house
when
five cops got shot up from a guy up in
the window you think that's good
what is that all about is that a cool do
you call that a cool
what do you call is that insurgents no
that's just called pathetic is what
you're doing
so january 6 is people that were pissed
off they went and did that that's
that's pathetic what was taking place
that wasn't a good thing
but to say it's a coup for marketing
purposes
words have consequences you have to be
careful with the words that are being
used anyways okay so let's let's go to
the next story here
number one story of business insider
yesterday philip morris how is that the
number one story of business since
until apparently gerard told us 7-eleven
came and took it away from them
philip morris international ceo says
cigarettes should be banned and the
company will stop selling marlboros in
the uk within a decade business insider
store the ceo
of philip morris the maker of marble
cigarettes outside of the u.s said his
company will stop
selling cigarettes in the uk within a
decade ceo jackie
ozak said on sunday that the move was
part of the company's goal to become
smoke free and to help
end the use of traditional cigarettes he
also called on the uk government to
outlaw cigarettes within a decade
comparing them to
gas empowered cars and they're said to
be barred from being sold in the country
starting 2030 philip morris
international separate from philip
moore's usa
which makes marbles in the u.s smoking
kills more than eight million people a
year according to a
world health organization did you just
hear that yeah
smoking kids this is the most confusing
story
so you're just shooting yourself in the
foot and ruining your own business model
like so basically you're saying you're
switching the weed boys
that's like what like what are you doing
what are you going all in on that weed
jules yeah uh this is big tobacco
basically saying guys
everything we've been doing for the last
hundred years or so bad
our bad my bad smoking actually kills
all the disclaimers and labels
go ahead and pay attention to those what
the hell is going on i'm going to be
fine
i'm going to be for real look i i
i had a i had like a a 12-year chewing
tobacco habit so and
and i got to tell you i i valued my
health so i stopped but oh man is it
good
oh man there's just nothing like
throwing a little lipper in in the
morning getting yourself the morning
paper and having
having your morning constitution all
that trash my name is gerard how are you
doing
put a little whipper in my mouth i think
it's funny i think it's funny is how
that my kids are gonna grow up with
legal weed and have to buy their tobacco
from a drug dealer man look you think
people are gonna stop smoking cigarettes
is there anything yeah i mean look i'm
sorry for the kids they're listening to
this you guys can hate me all you want
but
look there's nothing better than than
after a couple beers on a friday night
having yourself a dart you know i'm just
it is what it is man i
look you can you can do the natty
spirits it's uh those are all natural
it's basically like having a vegetable
kids but
no listen if you want to know anything
about cigarettes
just watch uh thank you for smoking it's
one of the best movies nobody's ever
heard of
if you've never started smoking don't do
it if you've never started chewing
don't do it it is addicting but if you
think tobacco is going away after all
these years
i mean literally tobacco was so powerful
the addiction was so powerful
that an entire continent moved to
another continent to farm it kai go to
pmi.com
go to pmi.com this is pmi.com okay you
go to pmi philip morris
international.com
you go to the bottom pmi products sells
and over 180 markets and many of these
we hold the number one or number two
position by market share six of the top
15 international brands
in the world are ours right there big
boat the number one
cigarette brand since 1972
the marlborough so here's what i'm
wondering what products do they sell
look at the number right there in 2019
marble volume outside the united states
and china was
260 billion cigarettes reinforcing its
leadership position as the number one
cigarette brand worldwide
i just want to know what's 30 cigarettes
that's a person what's in the world by
the way what's his response to the ceo
that basically said we're
stop smoking i i love the analogy they
made that cigarettes are now basically
like the gas-powered cars
so they're going electric so all right
there's some light bulbs should be going
on everything's going electric electric
now they're going jewel with great yeah
it's all about the jewels you will
you will own nothing be happy it's all
about the jewels or
vapes i was just rolling loud this
weekend you wouldn't believe how many
kids are vaping yeah
v it's a big hip-hop you vape or no no
i've never
no if i'm gonna if i'm gonna if i'm
gonna do i'm gonna do the real thing
people don't know adam sauce is actually
72 years old not a single wrinkle
not a single wrinkle he's actually 72.
thank you bro yeah yeah i'm a vampire
it takes one to know what what did i
tell you well that's a vampire
have you has anybody ever seen pat in
direct sunlight no
he's been saying this by the way behind
your back he's he's been going back
he go i go yeah what about you know
sleep july 4th we were at his house at
barbecue
he was in the shade the whole time he
was in the shade
i don't know about it all right so
anyway but maybe maybe just maybe
they're going to go in the weed
direction they're getting out of those
cigarettes go weed with it
bro look i i go the different direction
i go okay what's next
is you know is lay's gonna come out and
be like look there's fried potatoes
bad bad thing here's a question for you
okay let's let's judge a little bit is
that okay let's judge a little bit let's
play the judgment again
here we go no no here we go you ready
let's judge kai you ready or not
okay tell me what an nhl fan
the profile of an nhl fan give me the
profile of an nhl fan
they are a white man in their 50s
and they are they love uh actually
canada girls they love okay they love
canada
you're into an nhl game you're right
i'm gonna be a hockey fan let's continue
judging give me give me the profile of
an
nfl fan you're looking at him right here
there he is
yeah he's checking for the bill he's
checking his fantasy football scores
chuck
all right let me give you guys the grown
man culture paul escarsica paula
scarcely a big nfl
let's let's continue give me the profile
of somebody who watches
tennis oh
rob our style who watches tennis they
like they like headbands and
long white socks yeah yeah danielle
daniella the romanian yeah okay so let's
go to another give me a profile of
somebody
who goes to every single
nightclub five nights a week and listens
to edm 24 7.
profile of that guy they're a guy or
girl i'm thinking girls okay girls
give me the profile we'll give you that
25 year old bottle waitress type of a
girl
and you know they like wearing uh hyper
colors and they they're down to party
okay give me the profile of
somebody give me the profile of somebody
who's a hardcore crypto bitcoin like
it's
all about cryptocurrency give me the
profile who is the person whether they
look
also me david thank you who they're
a young man in their 20s ish
that has hasn't really made real money
yet okay
give me the profile of somebody give me
the profile of somebody who drinks jose
cuevo tequila
[Music]
i'm looking at it i look at it an older
tequila drinker
okay young people i would say ricardo
can take
ricardo can drink jose cuervo and not
even get buzzed
all right give me the profile of
somebody who drinks
louie the what is it
i don't know any of those people pat
you're gonna have to answer that one so
somebody's rich europeans
rich europeans fair because you know
some of those guys you party with those
guys so expensive
watch this but of course let's have a
couple of dreams
profile of a pothead who smokes sweet
every day
it's just the temperature is it the guy
who plays guitar pothead yeah potter
that smokes weed every day long hair
how old what does he look like whatever
she's 30 years old man you know they
smoked in college
got a weird beard going on got a weird
beard kind of like a ratty beard maybe
they're from norway all right so
so let's continue give me what we're
doing is being prejudiced i'm about to
get to the one
give me the profile of somebody who
smokes cigarettes
they got a raspy voice they're a grandma
no they were just born in china
that smokes a pack a day give me give me
a profile
60 70 year olds that have smoked since
they were 12. yeah they've been smoking
for 30 years leathery skin
yeah they can look like a catcher's mitt
used car old used cars
pants hands feel weird you have a [ __ ]
who shook their hands like hands feels
they're like a dry skin
they've got sandpaper european european
so if you know well european smoker's a
lot different than american smokers
european
uh you have a drink and there's smoke
it's okay yeah it's good look you have
my baguette and my little
front two teeth or yellow yeah yellow
yellow
teeth okay there you go so i mean listen
there's a profile of a cigar smoker
what's this yeah matzapala but what is
the profile of a cigar smoker
money a little more little wealthier i
don't understand man
from the libertarian standpoint you want
to smoke cigarettes go at it right i
mean i grew up in a family where
everybody smokes cigarettes from the day
i was born until i remember when my dad
finally had a
heart attack went to the hospital had
his open-heart surgery so lasted me
smoked cigarettes 1993.
i don't understand smoking cigarettes i
understand beer i understand tequila i
understand whiskey i understand cigar i
understand wheat i don't
understand cigarettes let me say
something yeah let me say something
please
what i don't understand what are the
torches what i don't understand about
cigarettes yeah are daytime smokers
where you're waking up you're having a
like listen you've got some helicopter
salesman car salesman helicopter
fingertips yellow
listen i will say this this guy says pat
i'm i'm smoking cigarettes drinking beer
and watching this podcast from india
way to go right raheed
listen america you might frown upon this
it doesn't happen
here we go but if you're not sex if
you're drunk
and you're having a nice time and some
lovely girl is over there
and and and you say hey we could share a
cigarette together icebreaker it's a
bonding moment and it's an icebreaker
and it's a power move yeah so am i
waking up
at you know 7 a.m and like time for a
cigarette
but if it's 2 a.m and you're a little
buzzed and you're out and about
and a pretty girl's right there and need
a light boom i'm sure
i'm sure this was marketing but all
movies and tvs in the 80s 70s 80s and
90s
yeah exactly i you know i i thought that
that was like a thing you were supposed
to like
pack a cigarette by the way i know i
know the first time i smoked a cigarette
was to impress a girl
okay how old were you seven or what was
your uh i was i just turned ten no
um two years ago for people that don't
know
okay funny i will say this i'm not
encouraging smoking
but if the the fellas out there wanna
easy layup move to get
you know if a girl's sitting there share
a cigarette
you're not your sheriff you're going
back and forth it's in your mouth it's
in her mouth
you guys are sharing a cigarette oh i'm
just saying
or
what about the hookah smoker what's
gonna happen to the hookah smokers man
what's
[Laughter]
with the perfect beard you know yeah and
uh
every sentence starts with bro
brother brother brother that's like
that's a lid
bro bro uh okay okay so we did a little
prejudice a little profile stereotypes
exist
this was kind of cool we got a little
bit sorry if we offended out of the
system here today
let's talk about what jp morgan is doing
very offensive what they're doing over
there so here we go
uh graduates should expect to work 12
hour days six days a week
to really master their jobs says
jpmorgan executive a business insider
story
graduate wealth management analyst
should expect to work 72 hours a week
then they'll be better trained for it
according to
mary callahan erdos the ceo of jpmorgan
chase's asset and wealth management
division based on the idea that it takes
roughly ten thousand hours to gain
base level mastery of something that's
going to take around five years if
somebody works 80 hours eight hour days
five days a week she said on wall street
it takes it's more like 12 hour days six
days a week that cuts you down to about
two and a half years
before you masturbate something and i
love the fact that they're just open
about it
in 2013 an intern of bank of america
merrill lynch's london office died of a
seizure
while it was conclusive and inquest
concluded that overwork could have
contributed to
21 year old moritz erdhod uh
his death unfortunate story obviously
there but the fact that the ceo is
openly saying if you want to make it
it's
12-hour days six days a week to cut down
the mastering the skill set in
half the time two and a half years adam
your thoughts on this i'm totally okay
with this as long as it's full
disclosure before you get the job think
about who's taking these jobs
very uh established you know you
think somebody's taking this job not
knowing those three hours that's what
i'm saying they know this yeah of course
no no don't take the job exactly yeah
look why are you taking this job because
you want to make
money because you want to make money
yeah it's a tough job
so if you're saying that it typically
takes five years to do this now you can
do this in two and a half years you
graduate you're 22 you're 23.
by the time you're 25 you put in the
crazy hours you're 25 you've made money
you're an expert i believe it was
malcolm gladwell that says you need to
put in 10 000 hours
um to be an expert at something and if
you can do it in half the time
and by the time you're 25 you're an
established expert in a field
by the time you're 30 you'll have multi
millions in the bank i think a lot of
people would want to do this
yes you're sacrificing your early 20s
and yes there's burnout and burnout is
real
but you know what you're getting
yourself into if that's a job you're
taking
i call [ __ ] i think it's nonsense
that you're going to take your lowest
wage employees
grind them into dust whoever makes it
makes it whoever does it wasn't worth it
you know meanwhile jamie dimon's getting
another freaking billion dollars or
whatever they're giving him
you know these aren't their lowest wage
employees these are right out of college
these are the lowest wage people right
these are
people fresh out of college figures
these are they're making sure there's
something these are
wealth management analysts these are not
all right you're your local
intern so this is this is not the best
they're like at the bottom of the food
chain well they're starting out at the
bottom
in the wealth management sector look
i i think these are people anybody
graduated from harvard business school
i would say this time to grind if
there's work to do do the work what i
don't like is
i've been in environments where the
culture is we're there from eight to
eight
and then people sandbag their way
through today not doing work because
they think they're gonna be there all
day
and it's what baseball we used to call
eye wash eye wash is like when people
just sit there doing nothing until they
think the coach is watching then they
start shuffling the papers and it's like
oh i'm doing work work work work look at
me working so hard
no like look if you have work to do do
work now i don't i didn't come
up in the financial industry i came up
in creative so
it was the exact opposite for us we just
you got paid for a project
and the best directors the best
producers that i was on it was like hey
we got the project done if we got all
our shots
get out of here we're not getting paid
by the hour like it's it's in that case
it's a race
you know when you do a commercial and
you've got two days and you've got you
know
essentially 20 hours two two shoot days
and then if you get done by 16 hours you
got all your shots and you got all your
pickups and everything like that
you're paying you're paying your crew
extra so what ends up happening the same
crew comes back
multiple times and they get better and
better and better and more efficient at
their job
because they know if i do my job and i
do it well we're getting out of here i
don't have
to be here until midnight tonight i'm
going to get out of here at 8 o'clock so
i've seen it from the other side
if you guys i haven't been in that
position so i should i shouldn't have
had such a
a strong opinion on that from the
beginning i do apologize for that but if
there is 12 hours worth of work to do
do the work compete i'm all for that but
if you're just setting an environment
where this is this is not the
environment where you're sitting around
buddy let me put this
in like paper pressure sure you you
you're it's a little bit of a reach but
i get it your world you're in your world
is not
uh this world your word the world is
project based
you go finish the project you're done i
get it that's the optics that's the part
you're in
in this world if you're gonna sit around
the 12 hours at the office and do
nothing you will be fired
in 90 days less than that this is not a
job
for you bro morgan stanley dean witter
your first year if you and this is in
this is an 01 when i got the job 20
years ago
if you didn't bring 10 million dollars
your first year in you're
fired if you didn't pass your series
seven the first time not second third
time
morgan merrill goldman you have to pass
it the first time you don't you're fired
right
if you don't pass it the first time
you're fired if you don't get 10 million
dollars your first year you're fired
there is no time to sit around and shoot
the [ __ ] and look at instagram videos
all day long and tick-tock and two other
twitter videos you do that it's over
with
you have to go out there network you
have to go out there shake hands you
have to go out there in the morning you
have to go out there to the
country club you have to drive the
appointments you have to you have to do
anything and everything it takes to be
a winner in this job so what does that
12 hours look like what is that 12 hours
it's non-stop you're either prospecting
you're either looking for clients you're
either networking
you have to be wrong or you're analyzing
you're doing it you're doing data
analytics
you're learning about what's going on
you're studying everything in the market
what's going on you're studying the
papers you're trying to see
what this analyst is saying what that
analyst is saying what just what's an
official
buy what's a hold what's a sell what
just change categories who got a better
rating
whose quarterly calls coming up let me
see what this guy's going to be doing
but most of this job is shaking hands
being in front of people are you
actually managing the wealth my
understanding was that there were
programs like there's a goldman
fund that you go into and they and you
you get into this and you get it like
so what why would i go with for example
okay why would i go with
you know uh jp morgan instead of
western mutual why would i go you're
gonna you you
everybody here brags that they have the
best money manager they have the best
fund they have the best whatever so
you're putting
you're gambling where you're putting
your money with goldman's gonna say
we're the best because you are able to
participate in certain things that
others are not like goldman says
to to get into goldman to have an
account with them to manage your money
it's 10 million
i was going to say you ain't got 10
million you can be this is goldman
doesn't let you get in with
less than 10. you're not doing the ten
thousand dollar buy-in that's bank of
america
goldman goldman is going to be the 10
million dollar client but if you're with
goldman here's what happens with goldman
you want an ipo to participate in uber
before anybody else is done yeah you can
go in how much you want to put in half a
million great you can go on because
you're part of the goldman family
those types of opportunities comes to
you but you know how many total advisors
goldman sachs goldman has
how many think goldman has no idea maybe
under 500.
400 go 400 that is all goldman's
goldman sachs are worldwide in u.s
goldman sachs's
office in dallas is half the size of
this office ten
estate they have ten ten
they have 400 financial advisors is what
they have
that is it to get a job with goldman
sachs probably a lot more in california
to florida versus
the item of the crop you have to be the
cream of the crop
now if you make it at goldman five years
later minimum
seven figure under if you're there ten
years and you're a killer
you can make five ten fifteen twenty you
can make money if you're at a place like
that
but is it easy to make it and stay there
absolutely not so
again if you want to you know we we we
look at sports and you're like hey to
get to the next level it takes a lot
okay four questions are you clear on
what you want to do with your life your
dreams your goals
number one most people are not i asked
this question last week in dallas
how many of you are clear everybody's
hands went up i said great i'm gonna ask
a question one more time
how many guys are so clear about your
dreams and goals
that if i bring you up on stage you can
recite it to everybody in 20 seconds
this is what happened
a thousand people in the room 50 hands
are up it was 800 hands up when i asked
it openly
then when there was a commitment to you
coming and presenting it to everybody
else their hands went up that's okay
great
so most of you guys don't even know what
your dreams and goals are i know what it
is to be there i've been there before as
well number two
let's just say you know what your dreams
and goals are do you know how demanding
that dream or goal is to become a
reality so a person says what
yes or what no i don't know how to
manage i want to do this like i don't
know how long it's going to take don't
know how demanding it is oh yeah i want
to make a millionaire do you really know
what it takes
like we talked about nobody takes a job
not knowing how much work they're going
to do
you know how demanding it is to be
that person it's a lot of work the
the greatest of the greatest comedians
that i read about and i go see what they
did they freaking had
no life for five ten years they went out
it's like
maniacal it's not the best life the
people who went and played in the
military and guys made it to the top
dude they were doing correspondence
afterwards
i wasn't doing correspondence afterwards
matter of fact i can tell you this two
and a half years in the military i've
never taken one correspondence class
my buddy took correspondence classes he
retired as a delta force
i got out as an e4 i was not taking
military seriously so i didn't have like
a
hey i'm going to go take correspondence
so let me go back at it how clear you
are about your dreams and goals number
one number two
how demanding is that dream like if it's
to win an emmy if it's two on an oscar
how demanding is that
number three is the tough question that
everybody secretly answers that nobody
knows you know what the question is
are you willing to meet
the demand required to have
your dreams and goals and vision become
a reality
and most the answer is what secretly
they say what i'm just not willing to do
it
i'd much rather go home and party and
the last one is the following and then
i'm gonna turn it over to you
the last one is when you sit there you
close your eyes
and you dream about whatever your vision
is whatever your dream is to become a
reality you're by yourself when you
think about it
does it get you emotional does it get
you fired up
does it get you to say oh my gosh like
you you get the chills all over your
body
if it doesn't it's not really that big
of a dream you know who i think of when
as you're explaining the story
the last great interview ever did with
kobe bryant yeah like this is exactly
the blueprint that he probably lived by
right am i clear on what i wanted allen
iverson i want to be an nba superstar
yes how am i do i know how demanding
this is going to be
oh yes you wasn't with me when i was
shooting in the gym by the way and he
checked all those boxes
it's a hall of famer but i have i have a
hard time who allen iverson yeah but
okay great so bring that up fantastic so
go there you ready
go there every time you move up
there is a next level you may be the
best player at
ymca league tuesday thursday saturday
league you crush everybody
you're the you're the rocks and when you
leave people are taking pictures with
you oh that's me on tuesday and then
and then you go play at an la fitness
league
8 am in the morning 7 8 in the morning
you're a nobody
but let's just say you eventually get so
competitive that you play good at the
l.a fitness place
then you go play against college
basketball players
and then you're nobody then let's just
say you get good enough to play for
college
then all of a sudden you have what it
takes to go into the nba you're actually
doing something you went into the final
four you made a name for yourself
you go into the nba then all of us are
like dude it's a freaking different game
these guys
are so much quicker then you get good
enough to be an all-star
now you're going to the all-star game
then you're good enough to go into the
playoffs
then you go into the finals then you see
the other guy handles pressure better
than you do
he's a champion you were a 14-year nba
veteran but the guy won a championship
you didn't
there's always the next level at every
level and the next level at every level
is more demanding and there are people
that eventually say
i'm just not gonna go at this level i'm
just not
i'm just not gonna go at this level by
the way and i'm fully convinced
gerard this mindset
is applicable to every industry
i am convinced in hollywood the guys who
eventually become the steven spielbergs
of the world
while everybody else is going out there
celebrating hardcore partying i'm well
i'm convinced those guys go out there
and they're working on their next script
and they're already looking at the next
thing almost every single person
i've studied who made it at the highest
level
you know the similar answer is like
what's your favorite movie you ever made
you know what they say i haven't made it
yet the next one yeah what's your
favorite championship
the next oh like what's the the point is
it's like my favorite ring is the one i
haven't gotten
versus the people always like well let
me tell you man back in you know
1993 when i did xyz that's the problem
al bundy scored four touchdowns
that's the problem so if you were there
in the world of competition
yes you want to get by the way just so
everybody knows so everybody knows this
dei you know uh
uh uh diverse uh equity and inclusive
the person who said these words just so
let me
read it the person who said these words
her name not his name her name is mary
callahan erdos the ceo of jpmorgan chase
assen and wealth management division
her name so this is not if it's a he or
a she
she says to make it requires 12 hours a
day six days a week
to make it a two and a half years she
says that this is not like
a bunch of men that are making other men
work hard and all this other stuff
no by the way i've sat with women in the
financial industry
let me tell you some of the most
impressive people i've ever sat across
beasts beasts you sit there they will
eat your
lunch and they're intimidating they're
so solid
because they can compete in this league
men fear these women so it's not
about this isn't about sex this isn't
about color this isn't about any
this is about are you willing to pay the
price to be the cream of the crop
in your industry how bad do you want it
are you willing to meet the demand and
i'm telling you gerard
i'm telling you 99
of the time you can eventually hit a
level that you're gonna either say i'm
content with this amount of uh
you know what we produce with a product
and in that moment is a breaking point
to say
you're gonna go a little bit more
because the other guy's going to go a
little bit more you're going to go a
little bit more like you know you do
this thing you
just visualization that's the one always
the next level you're always at the
bottom of the next level everybody's
always at the bottom of the next level
all of us well you basically had this
conversation with shaq right i mean
more or less so with kobe but shaq
doesn't want to have this conversation
but the whole idea
when he said how great would would shaq
be if you had your work
ethic be the best player jack said it's
the dumbest question anyone's ever asked
and he dm
he was pissed off and he blocked me so
jack come on the podcast let's let's
work this thing out all right the guy
again though
multiple time champion hall of famer
business icon you know there's i guess
okay
i don't disagree with anything you've
said i disagree with nothing that you've
said but just to give
i don't know another opinion all right
i've seen guys that do want it too bad
and they it's all they think about and
they obsess about it and then and they
go
uh i i i was one of those guys
especially it's all you think about it's
everything and then when when the wheel
breaks a little bit it breaks all the
way
like when when there's a little crack it
cracks all the way
that i think that there has to be some
sort of
to me it's like a ferrari right you can
take the best car in the world
and if you keep it in the red the whole
time and you push push push push
push it the best car in the world is
going to no one's ever said that
no one's ever said that by the way that
is a misconception right there gerard so
let me let me take you back
when you hear stories like that of a
person that gave everything and they
still didn't make it
it is such a discouraging story for
young kids that are sitting there saying
effort why am i going to give my best
it's a very discouraging story let me
let me explain
is worth it no okay for sure now it's a
different story but but let me give you
the other side
we will rarely talk about our f ups on
why we didn't make it to the next level
we will rarely talk about our f ups why
we didn't make it to the next level
rarely one day mario is talking to me
and i love watching mario play soccer i
mean it's just
if mario plays i want to watch this guy
guys got calves for days not just casper
days i just
like watching him play you know what he
said to me the other day he said you
know what
one of my biggest fears in life is he
says one of my biggest fears in life is
the fact that i can't ever play
soccer again can you imagine this guy
says one of my biggest fears in life is
that i can't play the game i
love playing okay this is him so
he tells a story he says one time i'm a
junior or whatever i mean sophomore
what is 10th grade whatever 10k is this
freshman is a freshman is night right
okay sophomores and groups so he says
i'm a sophomore right now and i'm
playing for the varsity team and he's
kicking us he's doing a great i think
he's the captain of the team whatever
and there's this moment where the coach
is challenging him and he talks back
and he just publicly you know goes after
his uh what do you call it his coach
and coach pulls him aside and he says
you know what you just messed up
everything
you're off the team you're going to play
you're never going to get playing time
with me
okay and he says i'm like i quit i give
up and he left
so then you hear that story and you say
okay
that's probably not a story you want to
tell publicly but mario's told that
story publicly
right here's what i did those stories we
all have
i have those stories where i was at when
i'm coming up i'm a six four and a half
guy what do you mean you didn't play any
kind of organized sports i have my own
stories
what i didn't want to do everybody has
those stories but sometimes when you're
saying a guy doesn't make it today he
gave everything he did this he did that
sometimes one to me is you just don't
have the talent to play at that level
that's number one which is true which is
very true max out
first of all you played semi-pro
baseball what are you talking about like
what percentage of the freaking kids out
of high school ever play college later
on seminar or maybe you could
hit the [ __ ] out of a fastball you
couldn't hit a card
the other day tell me tom's like yeah i
took gerard to a baseball game this is
tom's uh
you know commentary on taking gerard to
baseball he says i take the gerard to a
baseball game
and which was awesome thank you yeah he
said we go to a baseball game it's a
pitching deal which he loves and he says
we go to a place and the guy's throwing
pitches and
they're allowing people to hit so gerard
goes in and he grabs the bat he says uh
you're gonna let me use this metal band
and the guy says yeah you sure yeah okay
nobody knows who he is they're just kind
of like another guy that's coming trying
to hit our baseball
so the guy starts pitching tom's like
pat
gerard look like an mlb player everybody
was shell-shocked
with how beautiful gerard was hitting
the ball on the field or this isn't the
batting cage
yeah he says he was killing it people
like who is this guy
meaning a white cecil fielder
white cecil fielder what's the most home
runs you ever hit in a season 47
51. i don't know yeah 51. so anyway
i could see you being a cecil fielder
but the point is there's a little bit of
talent junior
there's a little bit of talent there's a
little bit of attitude there's a little
bit of ego
there's a little bit of you're not
coachable there's a little bit of nobody
tells me what to do there's a little bit
of your primadonna of who you were in
the high school because
sometimes when a kid knows from 10th
grade he's going to be an mlb
that's actually a bad thing yeah like
you know the kid that knows like this
guy's going to be in mlb
somebody needs to say brown when he was
going to the nba well just you you shot
you're right you just shut off
the weight bro don't listen you're like
dude i know what are you talking about
you're just a 60 000
your teacher what do you know i'm going
to be a freaking multi-million dollar
contract you have that
absolute arrogant no one wants to coach
you
no one's my guy's in a company right now
we have we've had a lot of different
people in the company right
the the number one earner is not the
most talented guy in the company and
they say it they say it
one of the best things i've i've ever
heard in a history basketball
was they asked who's the guy that came
up with uh triangle offense is it text
winner it's a text winner yeah
text winner who taught phil jackson
about the triangle offense so the
interview text winner they say text
you've been in this league for a long
time since a long time long time 50
years yes a long time
who did you coach
that knew the most about basketball he
says oh that's easy he said who he said
jordan farmer it's a jordan
point guard jordan pharma
he says why jordan farmer he says
because you couldn't teach the guy
anything
he knew it all oh man
think about that analogy
if you're listening to sales this is
techs
and by the way i like this game when he
was in the lakers yeah i like this game
and he went and played in china or
europe i don't know where he played
and he came back and he actually
recovered he ended up having the talent
of his career was good
so i think there's more to the story
than just okay so let me ask this okay
how do you reconcile those two things
and then come back and find that next
gear
if you feel like you've gotten as far as
you can go i
put the work done i've done as much as i
can and i've done the best i can
how do you then find that next gear in
another career or in that specific sport
you're still in or business
well what do you think should you should
you leave and create something else
here's here's what i tell you what what
what i would do
is number one like for me you know in
july of 2009 i said we're gonna have a
half a month
half a million licensed agents by 2029.
that's a pretty crazy vision too cast
at that time we had like 66 agents when
we started the company in september of
and i said we're gonna have a half a
million licensed agents crazy 29 30
years old fine
insane but why did i say it at first
when i got into sales and working at
valleys
i'm saying i'm like dude i suck at sales
gerard i was the worst sales person i'm
the best guy best in shape guy at the
gym i couldn't sell one membership
it can't be worse than the guy at la
fitness can not be
four weeks goes by eight week i go to
cisco i said cisco i'm gonna go back
into the army i suck
he said what do you mean i suck he said
before you quit just give it one more
month i said i said you have to realize
i'm the worst salesman in here
he says go and sell memberships at the
mall i said let me get this straight i
can't sell memberships at a gym with
equipment here you want to go sell
memberships at a mall
because i want you to go to fox sales
mall just go to fox so i'll go to fox's
mall
and i'm behind the desk you know
escalators behind me
people are walking i would not leave
here but the best guys were always there
i was always in the back
okay so i noticed this guy's time like
screw it i'm going to go to the front i
go to the front i sell my first
membership
girl comes never forget this girl nicest
girl 75 down 32 a month corporate
contract i'm like i sold the contract
i sold the member i'm not going back to
the army i was so excited this 21 year
old camera
finally sold the damn membership right
so
september of 2019.99 what's good i'm 20
years old right
30 days goes by i break the record i
become the rookie of the month and then
i come back and i become a manager
anyways things start taking off for me
then i get into the insurance space it
was
it was confidence is what you need
confidence came back up then i'm like
but i'm still partying i'm so distracted
i'm still all this other stuff then i go
into the insurance i'm like
this is getting hard i don't think this
is for me so you get past that face then
everybody's then you start making money
then start winning then everybody starts
telling you how amazing you are
you're freaking ridiculous bro
one of the greatest drugs one of the
greatest drugs that's not even a drug is
flattery
flattery ruins women men and
athletes and business people you're so
amazing you're better than your dad
you're better than this you're better
than like that kind of stuff when people
say
yeah this division is like dude you know
so you become that cocky so the words
i got lucky where people said other
things to me
behind closed doors okay i got lucky
they would say the opposite it's like
well we'll see a lot of guys have come
and they've collapsed
a lot of guys have come and they've
ruined their careers because of that
that that a lot of guys have come up
like you and they've done this
that's what i needed i feared losing it
all and i heard that messaging so now
you get to a person that says okay
i get to point i don't make it what do i
do at a level like that number one
i would get serious counsel like the
fighter
mickey tells dicky ma stop acting like
vicky's gonna fight again he's 40 years
old stop
lying to him he's never going to fight
again hard truth
hard truth from people that love you
that you know they're not going to lie
to you it's not easy to do it's got to
be behind closed doors you and them
then based on that you can't rely on one
it's got to be three or four because
they've got to give you different
perspective
and then at that point you got to make
that decision and move on in your gut if
you get a feeling that this is what it
is now
here's the other part some people hear
this message they will only go talk to
the people
that they know they're going to tell
them to move on i had a guy that told me
right for a way out looking for a way i
want the guys i'm a consulting
the stem fields they have a pizza shop
love these guys they
call me and they say um hey pat yes
we have made a decision we're moving on
from the pizza business we're going to
go into a different industry
i said really so yeah were you on it or
no did you hear my conversation with
them i said really you're moving on so
yes tell me why
oh we just know we're going to do better
in different businesses so okay
interesting
i said let me ask you a question uh is
it because you think you're going to do
different things in bet in a different
industry or do you think this thing got
really really hard and you just kind of
want to throw in the towel
well no i think it's because we want to
move to a different industry
i said can i ask you guys a question
here so you pay a lot of money to me on
a monthly basis
why are you bullshitting me what's the
point of you bullshitting me like you're
paying me like what are you trying to
impress me
don't don't try to impress me just tell
me what do you guys talk about late at
night in bed
how much do you hate your current
business because of how hard it is
and they look at each other and he says
just tell him just tell him
and she says pat coveted was hard
selling pizza during cover it was hard
it's the hardest thing we ever did
i said what happened to you guys telling
me nine months ago you guys want to
build a franchise doing 30 million
a year and all of a sudden you're
discouraged nine months later what
happened here
i said here's how i work when it comes
down to marriage you guys want to get a
divorce i said i believe in divorce
i'm not one that says you know what is
it called the uh
uh uh you know anyways the stuff you
know to death was part all of a sudden i
do think sometimes marriage does make
sense my parents got a divorce best
decision they made to get in a divorce
before you get a divorce 12 therapy
sessions
together with a therapist six by
yourself
if after that you guys are still
convinced you guys got to go out there
and throw in the towel guess what
go get the divorce and you gave it a
shot that's what i'm saying
that's what i'm saying so meaning before
you say oh it's not going to work yet
i'm going to go to the next business
because the guy asked me a question this
last week he said hey
what do you say to the insurance agent
that's struggling he's been having a
hard time last two years
i said listen you're either struggling
because you're not working
you're either struggling because your
attitude sucks you're either struggling
because you're not getting better
because the language
or you're struggling because you're just
newer in the business
and you haven't hit the five year marker
stick around five years
five years later give your best if
you're not making the kind of money you
want and the lifestyle you have
then consider moving on but if you do it
after 18 more months what do you know
about this industry you know nothing yet
so
there's a combination it's such there is
no black and white answer to it i've
seen some people that have such a big
upside
go talk to somebody that they know
they're going to say oh baby this is too
much work for you
go home you should take a break this is
too stressful that guy all he cares
about is money
and they ruined the guy's life and now
he's broke still living with mommy and
daddy
so it's very important who you go into
and talk to when you're all the way at
the
decision-making point relationship or
career i've heard you used uh
tell this story before and you talked
about who's in your ear and what they're
saying and uh
flattery and all that you've said
something to the effect of
when your top guys are killing it that's
when you kind of bring them back down to
earth
or when someone's struggling that's when
you kind of build them up you've said
this before right like
if someone's killing it they had their
best six months of their life or
whatever
you don't be like bro you're the killing
it you're the man you say hey
so tell us about that yeah it's a
mistake when a guy's killing it you
don't over build them up
because you know the one thing goes when
you win and you make
money or you're winning in sports
business life and anything
the moment you start winning paranoia
goes away yeah
once you start believing the hype
drinking your own
it's a motivating factor it is so
dangerous when paranoia goes away hey
man you just won
literally last night i would i left the
gym i'm like i gotta get back to the
office
i'm like good call me i got a phone call
and i was like i gotta get back
but we talked about this before and this
brings this whole thing full
circle man was i played with a lot of
dudes and i see
it's crazy because i see it now as like
a second wave of my life
i see it now with dudes that have been
in creative industry and the guys that
have been in their life
i think people you talked about partying
and losing focus i i think some people
seek that
out on purpose because it's easier for
me to say
i didn't make it because i started
drinking well i didn't make it because
oh man i got i got into the girls
yeah it's way easier to say if only i
hadn't drank
then dude i just wasn't getting if i
didn't have that ankle
everyone wants an excuse no one wants to
say yeah i did it and i just watched but
you seek it out just in case
like simone biles like i don't know
anything about simone biles from a wall
but she's a champion maybe she thought
man i just don't have it this time
anxiety or covet or something this this
it's better for me to back out with an
excuse than it is for me to not win gold
i can't see me as anything other than a
champion why you know what's the crazy
thing i don't know if that's true that's
a crazy thing we will never know
we because there are certain things in
life we will never tell the truth to the
world
to save face you will there are certain
questions you
will never ever know the answer to that
question
never there are a lot of decisions that
we make and we're very good at acting as
if we made the right decision to protect
our egos and protect our
position we're pros at it every one of
us in the world is pro at this
this isn't like you're better than
another person than another person
and every once in a while if you can
show to humane side that i effed up and
i wish i would have done something
differently
then people realize you're human and
they'd relate to you we all want to be
able to do that but it's
so hard vulnerability is really hard so
hard to do especially it's like the
memes that go around like everything's
fine
everything's fine
by the way one of my favorite podcasts
this was actually a very good podcast if
you're still with us you enjoyed it
subscribe to the channel we are i
believe uh
thirty one thousand one hundred away
from a hundred thousand subs to maybe do
this three times a week
and uh we will do this again thursday
same time back here take care everybody
bye bye
you